the entire USA Gymnastics Board of
Directors has resigned over the sexual
abuse scandal involving former women's
team dr. Larry Nasser he was in court
yesterday to face more accusers in
another sentencing hearing in all more
than 260 victims have come forward today
police in Michigan will apologize to one
victim for not pursuing charges in 2004
dr. Jon LaPook is following the story
John good morning good morning Nora last
week Nasser was sentenced to up to 175
years in prison for sexually abusing
seven girls this week's sentencing
focuses on Nasser's abuse of three girls
in another County over the next few days
at least 60 victims are expected to give
impact statements scum of the earth
is too high of a title for you back in a
Michigan courtroom Wednesday victims of
Larry Nasser scolded him and the
institution's they believe helped
protect him if someone with a little
molecule of wisdom with power at
Michigan State would have decided to
make a difference hundreds of lives
would be different today Michigan State
University where NASA worked is still
dealing with backlash after allegations
it ignored multiple warnings he was
abusing girls last week the president
and athletic director both resigned at a
contentious meeting Wednesday the
Michigan State University's Board of
Trustees voted in former Republican
governor John Engler as its interim
president despite objections the damage
that can be caused by appointing a
politician as an inferred president on
an already polarized campus is
catastrophic
the Nasr fallout continued elsewhere
Wednesday as a Michigan Police
Department admitted it missed a chance
to pursue charges against him in 2004
nobody was listening to us Brianne
Randall testified last week that when
she was 17 she saw Nasr for a back
problem she says he sexually abused her
and she reported it to Meridian Township
police according to the 2004 police
report released Wednesday
Nasr admitted he had touched Randall in
the genital area but provided police
with a PowerPoint presentation showing
this procedure is a medical technique no
charges were filed in a statement
Wednesday the Meridian Township manager
admitted we missed it
we
were deceived sadly they took your word
instead of mine police plan to answer
questions about the Nasir case and
apologize to Randall during a news
conference later today Michigan State
University has denied it ignored
warnings about Nasser's behavior Nasir
will be back in court tomorrow
he faces a minimum of 25 years in prison
in this latest case John thanks